on this episode we talk about why a ward
suck why college sucks and what sucks
suck you ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee shut up
so everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 54 of the askgaryvee
show before I get into the show today I
just want to show you the hot cocoa bar
that we have a fainter media this is
this is a this is a fun dynamic to
taping on floor 15 there's always
something ridiculous going on so there's
something to start to show with great
show except for the questions tomorrow I
will be at Wine Library from 11 a.m. to
6 p.m. hopefully you're watching this on
Friday for anybody who's watching this
on Saturday after it aired you missed a
huge opportunity
Brendan asks does vaynermedia focused
much on winning awards and what's your
take on the ad industry's obsession with
awards in general I'm running great
question one that I've been talking
about for a long time in these halls and
in the industry I think awards are horse
crap I don't even know why I'm not
saying horse because the reason agencies
want to win them is for two reasons
it allows you to recruit talent and they
use it as something to get more business
and what they're doing is they're
putting out work for clients that is
actually trying to get awards versus
actually trying to sell something and
that's my real problem with it I don't I
don't begrudge the agencies that focus
on it because I understand it a business
rationale but for me it's a unhealthy
culture because it takes your eye off
the prize which is actually do something
for business and for us you know we're
lucky because of our work and because of
my personal brand to be honest with you
we've been able to get a lot of new
business and now our work is the
word-of-mouth of our business and - as
you can tell people know this is the
right place to work so we don't focus on
it I understand why people do focus on
it
I think it's an energy sucker away from
the thing that matters which is you need
to sell something rich asks what advice
do you have for professors to engage
college students in the classroom what
about outside of class which is the
biggest thing for you and any professor
out there or if you're asking for
somebody is that professors aren't
relevant to a lot of their students
today more than ever because the
behaviors of how we act aren't mapping
meaning
so many people have emailed me like
literally because the show emailed me
that hey I'm in class right now and what
my professors talking about makes no
sense compared to I'm watching your
power I'm listening to your podcast
right now while my professors talking
because he or she are so out of
literally professors in major
universities that are putting kids in
debt right now are telling them that
there is no ROI in social media like
Ludacris horse crap - crap kick anyway I
think the biggest thing a professor can
do is to be relevant with them if you're
a professor right now and especially if
you're marketing your comms professor
right now and you're not jamming on Yik
yak and snapchat and the insta then
you're making a huge mistake because
you're out of touch with your since
you're saying dumb [ __ ] like hey kids
hey students we're gonna connect through
modern things like you know like just so
I I can't even come out of my mouth I'm
so disgusted with what's going on
universities across this country and so
its relevance there is a rolling and
checking the [ __ ] out going on in
classrooms all across this country and
it's sad because of the romance of how
professors think it should be versus the
reality of what it's like
Tanner asks what are your tips for
teenage bloggers to show brands that
they mean business Tanner brands don't
care if you're 14 or 41 or 4,000 by
having actual results they don't think
you're in business so I don't know have
traffic have followers show them
engagement that's business show me
results son to Nova asks how do you deal
with burnout to nova this is a great
question i personally selected this one
i saw to my twitter stream and sent it
to india show india i like when we do
that it's my favorite part of the show
uh you know it's really funny this is a
funny question i burn out once every
six or seven years I hit a real like a
spot like where I want to just check out
and I go to sleep I actually go home and
go to sleep that actually happen this
one actually want a real good run right
now I think the last time I did was when
we lost Texas at Wine Library couldn't
ship there anymore we lost like 4
million in revenue and I was just burnt
out like fighting the fight of like in
that world and so I just literally went
home and like 6:00 p.m. I went to sleep
I haven't done since then I was like mm
2 or 3 so it's been a little maybe it's
not even six or seven years but when I
hit my lowest point I do two things I go
to sleep immediately and two I make
pretend that my mom was killed and I
know that's an intense statement and you
should have just seen the collective
reaction but when I burnout from work
its intense when I burnout it means that
I'm hurt by whatever's going on in
business and I'm focusing on business
instead of the big picture and I
directly put my brain into a place of
what what do I really care about and the
second I do that extreme move I'm
already on the process of going back
upstream and so look I'm a positive
person I put things in perspective in a
very healthy way I think and so I don't
tend to burnout that often but a couple
times I've hit rock bottom it's been
sleep and recalibration alright here's
my real question which social media
platform that is currently an incumbent
do you feel will be extinct in five
years in 2020 which social media
platform that everybody's invested in do
you think will be extinct thanks for the
question Ashton um so I think the two
most vulnerable platforms are Tumblr and
Google+ and I think that because they're
just owned by big conglomerates right
you know for all my concerns about where
Twitter's going I feel like Dick Costolo
and team will figure that out and get
better Facebook Instagram snapchat ur
are really in a great spot the two
incumbents of Pinterest I think is in a
great spot about the sneeze possibly by
the way as I answer this question the
two incumbents that I'm most worried
about our
our Google+ and tumblr tumblr because
it's owned by Yahoo and and all those
politics of being independent but still
being within a big holding company and
Google Plus because Google this is a
positive by the way Google has shown me
the enormous ability to cut bait if
something's not working no matter how
big it was and I just have a funny
feeling that they may just come out in a
year or two or three and just say we're
cutting it we may get back into this
game we may not but this execution is
not working for us
I actually feel actually am almost
willing to predict that may happen that
I could see them cutting Google+ out
completely outright in the next 36
months
so those are two incumbents Ashton and I
appreciate the question speaking of
which question of the day which social
network are you most addicted to right
this second you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering them
oh crap wait subscribe do I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social so subscribe